Mein Name ist Arjildis und ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz Arzt-Sethik und ich höre den Namen mit Ihnen in einer Musikgeschichte.
Sind Sie ein Verstanden?
Aber natürlich.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Florian Just.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nach- und Vornamen Buch stabilen?
Aber natürlich. Mein Vornamen ist Florian, Friedrich, Ludwig, Otto Richard, Ida, Anton, Nordpol.
Ein Nachname heißt Just, Jodd, Udo, Siegfried, Theodor. Just.
Frau Just?
Herr Just. Florian ist ein männlicher Name.
Okay. Herr Just. Wie heißen Sie Herr Just?
34 Jahre ans.
Wann ist sie genau geboren?
Am 24. Januar 2002.
1992.
Wie viel liegen Sie?
Wie viel ich wiege? Entschuldigen Sie, warum brauchen Sie mein Gewicht? Das verstehe ich nicht.
Ich habe ein anderes Problem und Sie fragen mich nach meinem Gewicht.
Ja, diese Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Und Badmärch Index zu rechnen, sollten wir fragen.
Was ist das für eine Routine?
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Was fühlt sich sonst?
Ich bin heute Nacht wach geworden, weil mir hier auf der rechten Seite etwas komisch vorkam.
Und seit heute Morgen merke ich, dass meine rechte Gesichtshefte ein bisschen komisch ist.
Okay. Können Sie einfach lachen oder sprechen?
Ja, ich kann sprechen, aber es fühlt sich etwas komisch an.
Man hat das Gefühl, ich bin beim Zahnarzt. Das ist ein bisschen betäubt und komisch.
Sie fühlen sich traubhaft.
Ja, vielleicht so eine ganz leichte Traubhaft.
Das habe ich bisher noch nie gehabt.
Jetzt habe ich ein bisschen Angst bekommen.
Okay.
Können Sie wieder schlafen?
Nein, diese Gefühle haben.
Heute Nacht ist mir das auch gefallen, aber eigentlich ist es seit heute Morgen so,
seit neun Uhr ungefähr.
Jetzt haben wir ungefähr 12 Uhr, also seit drei Stunden,
habe ich das Gefühl, dass es noch stärker wird, noch schlimmer wird.
Können Sie mich?
Ja, ja, ja.
Haben Sie noch eine andere Beschwerden?
Hatten Sie etwas Unfall?
Nein, ich habe keinen Unfall.
Okay.
Oder hatten Sie vorher etwas Unfall durch?
Nein, so etwas habe ich vorher noch nie gehabt.
Das ist das erste Mal.
Ich bin eigentlich sehr gesund.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen, keine Operationen bisher, mache viel Sport.
Also das ist das erste Mal und deswegen habe ich auch etwas Angst bekommen.
Okay. Leiden Sie sich an etwas Selbststörungen oder Höchststörungen?
Also ich habe das selbst mal getestet.
Ich habe die Augen unterschiedlich untersucht, aber ich sehe alles ganz gut.
Ich habe keine Sehstörung.
Aber Sie fühlen sich jetzt auch taufheitlich gefühlt.
Ich fühle mich ja über der Wange und es ist ungefähr so auch so ein bisschen die rechte Gesichtshälfte.
Aber was mir vorhin jetzt vor einer Stunde aufgefallen ist,
als ich hierher zu Ihnen kam, da habe ich im Spiegel gesehen,
dass mein rechtes Auge, also die Seite, was etwas tauf ist,
da geht das Augenlied nicht so, das bleibt immer offen.
Auch wenn ich meine Augen zu mache, bleibt das Lied offen.
Ein ganz komisches Gefühl.
Und, erhören Sie sich in Ihren Händen, insbesondere in Ihren Händen muskulische Wehe oder taufheitsgefühlt?
Nein, ich kann alles gut bewegen, da habe ich keine Taufheitsgefühle,
ich kann alle Finger bewegen, ich habe auch auf beiden Seiten genau viel Kraft, da merke ich nichts.
Okay, hatten Sie für Herr Herzrasen oder Herzstorpert?
Nein, nein. Herzrhythmusstörungen habe ich nicht gehabt.
Ich war zufällig vor zwei Wochen bei meinem Hausarzt zu einer Routine-Check,
der hat bei mir Blut abgenommen, er hat eine EKG geschrieben,
mein Blutdruck gemessen, er sagte, es ist alles in Ordnung.
Haben Sie in der letzten Seite Febarschuhe oder Nachweite?
Nein, damit keine Erkrankungen, keine EKG-Trunken, kein Fieber.
Mit Ihnen in Schwindelig?
Nicht direkt, aber es ist etwas komisch im Kopf.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ab- oder Zurück genommen?
Nein, ich bin immer mit meinem Gewicht gleichgeblieben.
Sie trafen mich in Sport, Sie haben gesagt,
jetzt sollte ich diese Gespräche unterbrechen,
ich werde Ihre Witterperimente und Herzschlag beprüfen,
deswegen eine EKG-Ableite.
Okay, gerne, warum nicht?
EKG ist in Ordnung, wir haben einen Senusrhythmus, der Puls ist 68,
keine Rhythmustörungen, keine Ischimeteiten.
Okay, Sie haben...
Jetzt machen Sie eine neurologische Unterversuchung.
Wenn ich die Tasse trinke, dann läuft auf der rechten Seite,
ich kann den Mund nicht richtig zumachen,
der Tee oder die Flüssigkeit läuft ein bisschen runter
und wenn ich meine rechte Seite bewege, sich auch weniger.
Wenn ich versuche, die Backen aufzublasen, dann ist die Seite weniger.
Und ich merke, dass mein Auge nicht richtig zugeht.
Und auch wenn ich so Stirnfalt hin mache, dann habe ich keine Stirnfalt.
Aber mit dem Sehen habe ich keine Probleme.
Wenn ich mein Auge abdecke, dann sehe ich alles gleich, sehr gut.
Okay, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Nein.
Leiden Sie, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Vorerkrankungen.
Sie sind nie operiert worden.
Sie nehmen regenmetisch Medikamente ein.
Nein, regenmetisch habe ich nichts ein.
Wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich manchmal Ibuprofen,
aber das habe ich jetzt in letzter Zeit auch nicht genommen.
Haben Sie die Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ich habe keine Allergie.
Ist Ihnen einige Blutungen aufgefallen?
Zum Beispiel Nasenblutungen?
Ach so, nein, nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, ich trage auch keine Alkohol.
Ich lebe eigentlich sehr gesund.
Okay, Trosten, sollte ich noch eine Frage über Genössmitte.
Nennen Sie irgendwelche Droge?
Meine größte Droge ist die Alkohol.
Ich habe keine Droge, aber ich habe keine Droge.
Ich lebe in meine Schubnade.
Sehr gut.
Herr Just, lebe in meine Schubnade.
Herr Just, ich habe keine Droge.
Das ist meine große Droge.
Ich habe keine Droge, aber ich habe keine Droge.
Ich lebe in meine Schubnade.
Ja, sehr gut.
Und Herr Jürgen, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, sie leben und sind noch gesund, ja.
Okay, leiden Sie nicht an krönlichen Erkrankungen, Ihre Eltern, Ihre Mutter und Vater?
Nein, nein, nein, Sie sind gesund, wirklich, Herr Weisel, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, sie ist circa 5 Jahre jünger als ich, aber sie ist auch gesund, sie hat auch keine Erkrankungen.
Was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Ingenieur, ich bin Projektleiter.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und ich habe eine kleine Tochter, sie ist 2 Jahre.
Sehr süß, ich habe auch eine kleine Tochter.
Ja, oh, Geschwister können sehr liebevoll sein.
Ja, ich komme wieder so aktuell im Reichweite.
Und sie haben ungefähr 8 Stunden im Rechte gesiegt, Tolbheitsgefühl.
Und sie können nicht gut ihre Mut und ihre Rechte Augen zu machen.
Und sie haben keinen Unfall.
Und vor zwei Wochen waren sie beim Haus aus und es war alles in Ordnung.
Ich denke, sie haben eine Neurologie Erkrankungen, aber ich denke, dass sie eine neurologische Erkrankung haben.
Und deswegen kann ich nicht ganz genau sagen, was sie haben.
Und ich wollte noch ein bisschen Köpferlischunterzüge und einige, die haben eine Erkrankung.
Was meinen Sie mit Bildgebendenuntersuchungen, die Sie heute machen?
Nein, normalerweise würde ich Computer-Tomografie und gegebenenfalls MRI Magnetik Resonanz durchführen.
Ich bin ein Kernspin, wollen Sie durchführen.
Ja gut, gerne. Ich bin für alles zu haben, deswegen bin ich ja da.
Ich habe gehört, hier gibt es gute Ärzte, deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ich vertraue Ihnen und ich hoffe, dass Sie eine Lösung finden.
Ja, das macht eine große Sorge und ich habe ein bisschen Angst.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass Sie mir helfen können. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank für Ihr Zeitraum.
Und noch eine Kollegin noch fragen.
Noch Fragen.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, meine Arbeit.
Herr Gut, haben Sie letztes Zeit kalte Wetter getroffen beim Arbeiten oder beim Sport?
Ich habe die Frage nicht passen, ich kann es in der MSN lauter sprechen, bitte.
Haben Sie letztes Zeit kalte Wetter getroffen beim Arbeiten oder beim Sport?
Achso, nein. Ob ich mit kalten Wetter Kontakt hatte oder ob ich bei Ihnen mich erkehlt hätte, nein.
Nein.
Okay, danke.
Darf ich?
Herr Jürgen, ist Ihnen eine Schwellung oder Hautveränderung um das rechte Ohr herum aufgefallen?
Nein, ich habe keine Schwellung, ich habe auch im Spiegel geschaut.
Da sehe ich nichts mehr.
Ich hatte auch vorher am Ohr nichts gehabt.
Haben Sie auch noch eine Frage?
Geschmacksveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, also ich merke, dass es ein bisschen komisch im Mund ist, wenn ich, als ich mein Teel getrunken habe.
Aber Geschmacksveränderungen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Danke.
Darf ich?
Schönen.
Ja, meine erste Frage ist, ob ich die Prostörungen habe?
Wenn ich rede, ist der Mund ein bisschen komisch, aber ich kann normal reden.
Ich kann alles gut aussprechen, Sie hören jetzt meine Sprache, damit habe ich keine Probleme.
Aber es ist halt ein komisches Gefühl im Mundbereich.
Die eine Seite ist ein bisschen taub, und die andere Seite ist völlig normal.
Wie lange haben die Beschwerden aufgetauert?
Ich habe es ja vorhin gesagt, heute Nacht das erste Mal, und dann seit drei Stunden, also insgesamt vielleicht so acht Stunden.
Danke schön.
Herr Just, ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie schwindelig?
Ja, so eine leichte Übelkeit, vielleicht aber das stört mich nicht.
Schwindel nicht direkt, aber ein bisschen komisch ist mir das im Kopf.
Ich habe keine Fragen gestartet, Jan. Können wir erst als gestrichen anfangen?
Lieben gerne.
Aber wir fragen nicht über Ihre Familienanahmenese.
Hatte gefragt.
Okay.
Mutter ist gesund, Vater ist gesund, haben kleine Probleme, Schwester ist gesund, alles gesund.
Ja, nur möchte ich wissen, wie sind Sie hierhergekommen?
Ich bin selbst mit dem Auto gefahren.
Das Auto steht hier vor dem Gym.
Ja, können Sie das schaffen?
Ja, da habe ich kein Problem.
Wie gesagt, auch mit dem Sehen habe ich keine Probleme, auch mit dem Fahren, das war alles okay.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Was kann fangen, Jan?
Ich kann versuchen.
Guten Tag Herr Roberts.
Guten Tag, wie geht es Ihnen?
Es geht mir gut. Ich habe einen neuen Patientin aufgenommen.
Ja, einen Patienten aufgenommen, das ist schön.
Immer so nett und freundlich wie immer, das ist aber schön.
Dann erzählen Sie mal, was haben Sie hier für einen Patienten?
Ja, es geht um Florian Just, der 34 Jahre Patientin.
Er kam heute zu uns seit 8 Stunden bestehende, fassiell paralyser, fassiell paralyser.
Er kam heute mit einer seit 8 Stunden bestehenden, Sie haben schon die Diagnose gesagt, Sie müssen das beschreiben.
Die Diagnose kommt am Schluss.
Okay, beschreiben Sie das.
Er kam heute mit 8 Stunden bestehenden, seit 8 Stunden bestehenden.
Er kam heute mit 8 Stunden bestehenden, im rechten Gesicht Parastöse und Parastöse und Parastösein.
Parastösein oder Kribbel Parastösein.
Parastöse, ich weiß nicht, ob man das als Paralyse gleich bezeichnen kann, aber Sie können das auch in Deutsch mit einer Kribbel Parastöse oder mit Taubheitsgefühl.
In der Prüfung müsste ich die medizinischen Fachbegriffe benutzen, glaube ich.
Ich finde, dann gibt es Kribbel Parastösein.
Gibt es Parastösein oder Hyp-Hyp-Estasy gibt es auch, das ist natürlich ähnlich, da gibt es viele Unterschiede.
Das muss man sich nochmal genau lesen, was bedeutet Hyp-Estasy, was ist eine Kribbel Parastösein.
Paralyse ist, glaube ich, ganz etwas anderes. Schauen Sie mal nach, was das bedeutet. Paralyse.
Wir haben eine Hyp-Estasy oder eine Kribbel Parastösein.
Diese Beschwerden, mit der Zeit Schlimme, progradiert, umfährt und sehr frei gilt.
Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Also ich glaube, jetzt muss ich ein bisschen auf die Grammatik achten.
Mit der Zeit wurden die Beschwerden schlimmer, dann wurden die Beschwerden schlimmer.
Oder die Beschwerden sind seit heute Morgen pro Gradient.
Okay, ich hatte da und da drauf.
Unfall und Zerfabragi und Tashikari oder Arithmi gefühlt wurden verneint.
Arithmin wurden verneint. Arithmi gefühlt ist ein falscher Begriff.
Arithmin wurden verneint.
Er war vor zwei Wochen bei seinem Hausarzt.
Es war alles in Ordnung.
Als Vorerkrankungen, Voropies und Medikamente.
Darf ich kurz unterbrechen?
Sie können hier ergänzen. Es war alles in Ordnung.
Was hat der Hausarzt alles gemacht?
Die Ergänzung der Hausarzt hat eigentlich die Vitalparameter untersucht, hat Blut abgenommen.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Er hat keine Vorerkrankungen und wurde nicht operiert.
Er wurde nicht operiert oder hat keine Operationen bisher.
Er hat keine Allergie.
Als Familienanamese gab er nichts.
Seine Familie ist alles gesund.
Als Familienanamese gab es nichts.
Das ist nicht ganz korrekt.
Als Familienanamese gab es keine pathologischen Erkrankungen.
Oder als Familienanamese ist es leer.
Das Begriff hat man auch.
Oder als Familienanamese ist es unaufgängig.
Es gab nichts. Es ist kein gutes Deutsch.
Ich habe die Kapitänin kaputt.
Kein Problem.
Er war in Grüne und verheiratet.
Er habe eine gesunde Tochter.
Wie alt ist die Tochter?
Sie ist 2 Jahre alt.
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist chemische Apoplex.
Sie ist chemische Apoplex.
Sie ist im Begriff in dieser Konstellation eigentlich nicht verwendet.
Sie ist chemische Insult.
Wir fragen in der Runde die ersten Verdachtdiagnose.
Sie haben nur eine neurologische Symptomatik.
Die Hände sind in Ordnung, Beine sind in Ordnung, keine Sprachstörung, keine Sprechstörung, keine Stuckstörung.
Nur peripherige Gesichtsprobleme hat.
Meinen Sie, dass es eigentlich jemals ein solches?
Ich bin der erste Verdachtstdiagnose.
Was hinst du vom Facharzt?
Ich bin Algemeinmediziner.
Algemeinmediziner, dann müssen Sie die erste Verdachtstdiagnose.
Das war auch hier in dem Chat, das hat man gesehen,
ist wenn man nur an der Gesichtspflicht hat,
dann ist die erste Verdachtstdiagnose Arbeit.
Sie haben das gleich in der Vorstellung vorhin schon benutzt.
Eine Periphera,
Fazialis,
nicht Paralyse, Paräse.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man im Türkisch Paralyse sagt, aber Paralyse ist etwas anderes.
Schauen Sie bitte nach, was das bedeutet.
Paräse, Paralyse,
Hemiplegie, Hypesthesie, Kribbelparästhesie.
Diese Begriffe sollten Sie genau wissen,
damit Sie das nicht verwechseln.
Sonst passiert Ihnen das, wie es bei uns in der Anatomie passiert ist.
Da hat der Professor gefragt,
und dann sagt der Student,
Fahrungs ist gleich lahrungs.
Und dann ist er durchgefallen.
Fahrungs ist nicht gleich lahrungs.
Sie dürfen diese Begriffe nicht verwechseln.
Sie müssen sie beherrschen.
Deswegen Hausaufgabe bis nächste Woche,
bitte diese Begriffe genau lernen.
Wenn Sie einen neurologischen Patienten vorstellen,
das ist die Physiothophtas, glaube ich.
Ja, leider.
Wenn Sie einen neurologischen Patienten vorstellen,
mit dieser Vorstellung werden Sie bei mir durchgefahren.
Tut mir leid. Die Grammatik ist nicht gut.
Da ist auch ein bisschen aufregend dabei.
Aber Sie müssen auch die Begriffe genau wissen,
was Sie sagen.
Nicht einfach etwas sagen, es gibt keinen guten Eindruck.
Das ist nicht gut.
Deswegen diese genauen Begriffe auch,
wenn Sie einen orthopädischen Patienten haben,
wenn Sie einen Schmerz beschreiben,
wenn Sie ein kaviales Problem beschreiben,
dann müssen Sie diese Begriffe
zumindest die wichtigen Begriffe
genau wissen, was das bedeutet.
Die erste Verdachtstheagnose,
das fragt man in der Runde.
Haben wir eine Neurologin unter uns?
Oder ein Hinoarzt?
Eine perifere, spazialis, Harese.
Und die Frage ist vorhin,
ob Geschmackstörungen vorliegen.
Weil der Geschmack ist ein anderer Nerv.
Welche Nerven macht, welcher Hirnnerv ist?
Wir wissen nicht, welche Nummer.
Welcher Hirnnerv ist das?
Gesichtsnerv.
Nummer 7, 8, 10, 12, 5.
Echt?
Ist spazialis 5?
Das kann ich nicht weiß, ich weiß es nicht.
Oder 7?
Sie gucken nach.
Welche Nerven?
7.
5, 7, 7, 7.
7, 7, 7, 7.
Also auch das sollte man wirklich gut wissen.
Denn der Nerv, der die Zunge innerwirt und versorgt,
ist der Nervus, Hypoglopsus, glaube ich.
Das ist der Nerv Neuroin, meine ich.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber das muss nur ein bisschen die Hirnnerven.
Welche Regionen die Hirnnerven genau versorgen,
sollte man in der Neurologie gut kennen.
Okay, also erste Pädatziagnose,
der Arbeitsdiagnose, perepharephazialis,
Hareser, rechts.
Okay, weitere Differenzialdiagnose,
ja Doktor, dann machen wir das los.
Doktor, bist du schon weg?
Ja, nein, ich bin hier.
An Differenzialdiagnose.
Ich chemische in Zürich.
Wo, wie chemisch, rechts?
Rechts Hirnig oder links Hirnig?
Irgendseitig links Hirnig.
Links?
Ja, wenn die Paräse oder die Neurologische Problematik
oder Parästhesie rechts ist,
dann ist es links Hirniger, cerebral Insult.
Okay, weitere Differenzialdiagnose.
Sie können ablesen, Doktor.
Ja, ich bin da.
Bitte?
Multibleschlerose.
Ja, MS ist die Abkürzung.
MS oder Multibleschlerose, jawohl, was noch?
Statt cerebral Insult,
welche Vorstufe oder andere Beschreibung
gibt es für eine sehr kurzfristigen cerebral Insult?
Was kommt in der Gleichzucht?
Traktorische, transitorische, Bischee.
Bischee, gucken Sie nach.
Die Abkürzung ist T.A.
Okay, T.A.
Noch mal durchgefahren.
Noch mal Differenzialdiagnose.
Was gibt es noch?
Trans...
Ich chemische ablesen.
Andere Differenzialdiagnose.
Woran müssen Sie noch denken?
Was kann es noch sein?
FSME, also eine, was bedeutet FSME, der Doktor?
Was heißt FSME?
Für die, die so wollen, die wissen.
Nein, stopp, stopp.
Ja, der Doktor soll es sagen.
Doktor, was ist FSME?
Ich wollte nicht, Herr Männer.
Ich habe jetzt...
Ich habe keine Paratomusik.
Grüezi, nochmal Meningo encephalitis.
Also eine Encephalitis.
Was kann das, das heißt, wenn ich Encephalitis sage,
dann muss man auch an einem Meningeatis denken, oder?
Kann auch sein.
Okay, was kann noch?
Jetzt kam der Tipp noch.
Eine Differenzialdiagnose noch und dann machen wir Schluss.
Ja, ein Zimmer hat...
Ein Zumer, natürlich.
Ein Zumer, ein Zumer, was auf den Gesichtsnerv drückt.
Entweder hier außen oder vielleicht sogar zentral.
Aber Sie machen eine Computodomographik,
deswegen wollen Sie das hersehen.
Okay, ich lasse Sie...